hello my name is endre Kapadia and this
afternoon my colleague Adam stirs bond
ski and I will give a talk on limits
unlimited we will describe the new and
exciting functionality for limits in
version 11 point 2 we will talk about
various kind of limits and also show a
comparison with literally 1 million
examples with some other software to
show how powerful version 11 point 2 is
for limit computations so changes in
function limits so first we extend the
univariate limit scope so univariate
limit has been here since version 1.0
but we have improved it in eleven point
two we introduced undirected limits so
setting direction goes to reals gives
limit from both directions both real
directions and direction goes to
complexes requires limit from all
directions in the complex plane to exist
limit can now return conditional results
it will return in the terminates in the
terminating if it proves that limit no
limit exists so this is new and we
introduce multivariate limits now that's
something that was not here at all and
mean limit and max limit otherwise known
as limit inferior and limit superior and
there is a whole new documentation for
limits much more examples and the new
type typesetting which I will show
throughout the talk
yeah
okay so major extension of the
univariate limit is we added new
implementation of grunts algorithm that
there was implementation of Bruns
algorithm but which was limited to
explode functions or only compositions
of explanations logarithm no it also can
can use can be used for other func are
the real functions so here's the first
example that the limit that we could not
compute in the previous version now we
can here's something slightly more
complicated here this
and so we used the benchmark of 1
million limit collected collected from
Wolfram Alpha and we improved success
rate from 93% to 97% or in other words
failure rate this is more than twice
lower than it was so first undirected
limit so earlier versions of limits were
computed directed limit so if you if you
just say limit the direction would would
be from the larger values larger real
values so what's now now you can say
direction from above and a bit types
it's nicely as X goes to 0 plus like the
natural mathematical notation and for 1
over X from the right hand side the
limit exists and is passing Finity but
if we take the limit over the real which
is the new default doesn't exist from
the right hand side this passing thing
left hand side is minus infinity so the
limit does not exist so to get the old
behavior one can use direction goes to
minus 1 or from above to get the same
the same behavior our direction goes to
complex this requires the limit to exist
from all directions in a complex plane
so here we have a function that where
the limit from both both real sides
exist it's zero but limit over the
complexes does not exist and we can
check that if we take direction from
positive actually this one is from
negative complex axis then we got plus
infinity
a function of the results so now we can
return conditional evaluate results so
they're odd limit would fail if if it
required some condition non non generic
conditions on parameters and the new
limit will introduce some condition and
give you a conditional expression output
like here if n is greater than zero then
the limit is infinity and the conditions
are chosen to be consistent with
assumptions so with the same example but
now we say that M has to be less than
zero and you came up with
value for n less than minus 1 so it's
consistent with with and the value is
zero so it's different and if we say
generate condition goes to none so if
you don't want to get get conditional
results you can say generally generate
condition goes to none and it will not
go into the code that generates the
condition and there is one more setting
generated condition goes to false which
well the conditions are generated but
not reported not if you really don't
want to get conditional expression as
the output just won't limit that's why
it's somewhere that that's the setting
another difference with the older
version so right now if we take the
limit does not exist we get
indeterminate so that means that we have
proven that the limit does not exist so
that's that's considered better than
then returning interval interval which
is returned if we cannot prove that the
limit does not exist but we have bound
on the set bounds on the set of limit
points so so like in this case that this
is too difficult for us right now to
prove that the limit does not exist here
but we can easily bound the set of limit
points and its interval - to - to the
older versions Mathematica would we're
always returning intervals in such cases
when it could compute interval so so for
sine we would get the interval minus 1 1
and if somebody prefers to get bound on
the explicit bounds on the on the set of
limit points then there is a method
allow indeterminate output goes to false
with that we will always that interval
if we can get it
so multivariate limit so the width in
the new version of Mathematica we have
multivariate limit so it's limit as x
and y go to 0 so so it's limited to
dimensions and we can compute for for
rational functions we can always compute
it let's see the plot the function
actually is continuous here it has a
limit there's a different rational
function and it does not have a limit we
can see it on the plot slightly you can
see that the limit can be we have ho
interval of limit points at 0
okay so that this shows that the limit
is computed over the set of points where
the function is defined so we have a
function that where the denominator is
zero with X is equal to Y so on the
cross the function does not exist but
everywhere else where the function is
defined the limit exists so the limit
will report the limit exists and is
equal to minus 2 at 0 3 variables you
can prove that it doesn't have a limit
so a complete algorithm exists for
limits of rational functions but we have
many special case method for for other
cases where for more general functions
and this sucks so again we have a
benchmark extracted from Wolfram Alpha
hundred and twenty thousand multivariate
limits and the success rate was 91%
minami maxim it so we can compute limit
inferior limit superior or functions for
instance for this combination of trig
functions the the limit inferior is this
number and the superior other I will
show it on the path babes these are
numbers real numbers here they are the
the the lines to correspond to the
computed numbers so the weekly function
stays between the those numbers now it
will tell you indeterminate so in this
unless you you set the option that makes
interval preferable to to indeterminate
so the preferable is indeterminate
because it says that we prove it we have
proven that the limit does not exist in
interval the limit may still exist might
right in this particular place you
probably will get the tight interval
because it's the same method that
computes mean minami that much maxima so
but but in general is no guarantee right
so the very safe way to get tight limit
is to use millimeter Maximus
yeah so this is the same example we can
yeah so because we can we can we can
plop the bouncer so you can see that the
function is between the bound min and
Max it
here's another function so that that's
the case of trig functions which not
commensurate periods or periodic
functions with not coming through eight
periods and we can this is a really
irregular function the the previous one
was was it was a periodic function the
combination of two tweaks now we get
function which is not periodic it's to
sum of three three other functions no
periodic but it probably never never
reaches the you know the maximum value
an even value is in a very equal to two
mean limit and Maxima in the limit
that's that's what we get
here's a larger part of the same
function
Thank You Adam so in the remaining time
I'll talk about discrete limits in brief
and then talk about documentation and
benchmarking and how we have tried to
see how good we are in this release so
for discrete limits the question is
what's the motivation firing the speed
limit well the point is that many
processes in nature inherit discrete so
if you have a discrete process then you
definitely want to have a kind of
discrete limit so the other nice
animation created by each eye for seeing
how the area of a circle gets
approximate by areas of polygons and so
clearly that's a discrete process you
want to use a discrete limit for it but
you go beyond that go to number theory
many things are discrete you might
sometimes they'll continue approximation
but number three really is where
discrete things take precedence you go
to signal processing you have digital
signal processing where things are
discrete and of course many dynamical
systems let's say in the chaotic case
are defined discretely so you don't need
discrete limits all the time and we have
kind of been able to compute them
usually incorrectly in previous versions
so we didn't need this new layer of
solvers for discrete limits and so we've
gone ahead and added discrete limit
discrete max limit and discrete min
limit which are the discrete
counterparts of limit maximum so for
example over here you have sine of n pi
that's just 0 and this all one knows
that the N over there is just an integer
that makes life much more convenient for
everyone and of course if you're doing
college calculus you definitely want to
have it discrete limit sequence limits
is chapter 11 or whatever of every
textbook on calculus to go to whatever
we've done discrete calculus in the past
for a long time that require discrete
limits so we definitely need these
functions and now they are there okay so
some examples of discrete limits which
go a little beyond the continuous case
so one example of your would be
periodic sequences where you have
something like a mod and the sequence
now oscillates goes up and down from in
this case goes one from one to five so
of course the limit doesn't exist so
with the new philosophy its
indeterminate but surely we can compute
the discrete max limit and the discrete
so that's one and five as expected okay
another example the so-called densely
period a periodic class so things like
silent and cosine n are quite hard to
work with in the discrete case to prove
that the limit of sine n goes to
infinity as n goes to infinity the
indeterminate it's quite hard but
fortunately we have the technology for
doing this now and so if you look at the
plot oh here it's wildly chaotic goes
between 1 and 2.2 roughly so the
discrete limit does not exist but using
Adam's technology for Max and min we can
simply forget the fact that n is
discrete for a few minutes and get
exactly the same answer that you would
in the continuous case so that's the
idea of passing from discrete to
continuous when required and of course
in this example the main limit is just 1
now we spend some time looking number
theory that's a big area but we have
made a beginning I would say this time
we keep going back in that direction so
for number theory things like the prime
number theorem where you have an
asymptotic estimate for let's say the
primes is now known to the screed limit
not to limit because it's a discrete
problem and of course you look at the
partitions of an integer again there are
formal eight your Hardy and RAM illusion
which will give you a nice asymptotic so
those formally unknown and they work
quite well in tandem with other particle
system the discreet limits are really
proving to be quite useful but it's a
final example here's a recursive
sequence that's the kind of see when you
let's say study fix
point theory or chaos or something of
that sort so that's a nonlinear
occurrence and here's the first term you
want to find a limit at infinity so
that's a new convenient notation just
say X of infinity and you get back the
fixed point essentially so you get back
a root object whose approximate value is
0.45 and you can then visualize the
convergence of that sequence to its
limit and it's pretty fast so what we
done will actually took all the 50
examples on mathematic on math Stack
Exchange and we made sure they worked
with our new functionality and then
within a few day of shipping 11.2
someone asked the same question on
mathematical exchange and I quickly
replied it's almost like I was waiting
for that to happen and it's nice when
you do things which are really useful so
because sequence limits are actually
quite an important advance for this
particular area okay so I love pull back
and look at the whole limit
functionality so we really worked hard
when I say we it's really eater in this
case who's worked very hard to make the
reference page for limit discrete and
etcetera really really modern and
up-to-date and so if you look at the
limit page it's completely redone so
there's some nice notes from Roger and
an illustration from Tim who's an expert
in this area there are lots of scope
examples many more than the six or ten
or whatever they were before lots of
applications from our experience with
college calculus benchmarking so
generally speaking this is a complete
introduction to limit in the system so
so indiscreet Lehman etc I've got ways
to typeset things so if you want
information the reference page is now
the place to go it's completely up to
date as far as what in 11.2 is concerned
so documentation is a very important
advance for these and finally
we wanted to check how good we are so I
asked Michael trot can you give me some
examples from Wolfram Alpha for the
multivariate case I thought he might
give me a 50 100 or 500 maybe he sent me
100,000 examples in a package and so he
started testing them and so when I say
we I mean Henry Quang who's an expert at
benchmarking all kinds of things so we
ran the benchmark with the Wolfram Alpha
limits and compared with maple that took
some time but it turns out that we
actually do 91 percent which is what I
hadn't mentioned and maple does 76
percent of that benchmark which is quite
good proof that we've done a pretty
complete job on the multivariate side so
meanwhile I got brave and asked Michael
can you also give me some univariate
exam so he's only 1 million of them so
we ran those and this time we ran them
with version 11 point 2 maple and same
PI which is relatively new now I believe
simple into our multivariate limit so we
only have the univariate test on
comparison but what happened over there
was that version 11 point 2 gets 97% of
them right
maple gets 91% right right if it isn't
right sorry and simp I gets as far as
saying so you have these huge gaps
showing up and it is very large-scale
testing and the reasons for difference
of various even things like conditional
expression indeterminates
are really proof the limited exists and
I think that these improvements are
really proving to be crucial for our
benchmarking and other so we have all
these vast tests and we totally share
some of them with people outside so we
picked 1,000 motivated examples and
sometime next week I'm hoping to publish
a blog with blog post with saw the
examples that's 237 megabytes worth of
multi-varied limit examples which we let
people have a look at these are really
the most difficult examples and I didn't
just finished looking at each of them
individually this week to make sure that
they are all fine so we have been
testing a large scale we try to do our
best to look at textbooks other social
etc and I really think that these
benchmarks are now telling us that limit
in version 11 point 2 is extremely
powerful well documented well tested
ready for universal it's very satisfying
that it's all ended this way okay I'll
stop over here with a few remarks so the
main point I guess is that in version 11
point two you can explore the world of
limits you don't need to say univariate
or functional sequence of what we can do
what you can limit you want it all works
nicely so we really have the world of
limits opened out to us now and to go
further we like to improve series
because that's where all the work gets
done you want to have a better series
object which understands much more the
asymptotic philosophy which you are
working on and of course we want to
improve other functions like record
asymptotic be solid cetera this morning
so together we will have a pretty
complete set of asymptotic functionality
in the next ready it all so this is what
is happening on this side and thank you
very much for listening
any questions